- As you probably know, Rudy Giuliani
has been suspended from
the practice of law
indefinitely and he may be disbarred soon,
but what's going to happen now
and can he still practice?
Well, I was curious about that.
So, I looked it up.
A lot of people thought he
was only barred in New York.
That's not actually true.
Rudy Giuliani is also barred
in the District of Columbia.
Side note, this is
important because he filed
an affidavit in one of
the election related cases
where he said that he was
a member of good standing
of the DC bar, in fact, he
hadn't been paying his dues.
So, he was not in fact in good standing.
People were wondering whether
that meant that he had
perjured himself in those election cases.
But, the more important point
is that now that he's been
suspended in New York,
according to the DC bar rules,
he has an affirmative
obligation to notify DC
about the suspension and presumably DC
will issue a reciprocal
suspension against Giuliani.
So he's not going to be able
to practice in New York.
He's not gonna be able to
practice in DC and we're not going
to see Rudy Giuliani
in court, anytime soon.